but that's where visionary leadership
comes in right yeah somebody needs to
roll in and say
then take to take the leap well it's
it's partly take the leap but it's also
partly take the hit
take the head right so so so so you can
draw all the graphs you want that show
that you know if we leap from here
you know you know the you know on our
present trajectory we're doing this and
there's a cliff
if we um force ourselves into it into a
transition and we proactively do that
we can be on the next wave
but there will be a period when we're in
a trough
and pretty much always there ends up
being a
trough as you leave the chasm but
the way that public companies work
on this planet they're reporting
every quarter and the one thing that a
ceo
must never do
is take a big hit take a big hit
you know over some some quarter and and
many of these transitions
involve a big hit for a
a period of time you know one two three
quarters
and so you get some companies
and you know like tesla and amazon
are are really good examples of
companies that take
huge hits but they have the luxury of
being able to
ignore the stock market for a little
while
and that's not so true today
really but you know in the early days of
of both of those companies um
you know like like like like like they
they both
did this thing of you know
i don't care about the quarterly reports
i care about how many
how many happy customers we have yeah
right
and having as many happy customers as
possible can often be
um an enemy of the bottom line
yeah so how do they make that work i
mean amazon operated in the negative for
a long time it's like
investing into the future right but
you know you know so amazon and google
and
tesla and facebook a lot of those had
what it would amounted to patient money
um often because the there's there's
like a charismatic
central figure who has a
really large block of stock
and they can just make it so
so what uh on that topic just maybe it's
a little small tangent but
uh you've gotten the chance to work with
some pretty big leaders
what are your thoughts about intestine
elon musk
leadership on the amazon side jeff bezos
all of these folks with large amounts of
stock and vision
in their company i mean they're founders
yeah either
either complete founders or like early
on folks
and uh they're they amazon have taken
leave a lot of leaps uh and
you know uh that probably at the time
people would criticize
as like what is this bookstore thing
why yeah and and
you know bezos had a vision and
he had the ability to just follow it
lots of people have visions and you know
the average vision is completely idiotic
and you crash and burn
um you know the the silicon valley
um crash and burn rate is pretty high
um and they're not they don't
necessarily crash and burn because they
were dumb ideas but
you know often it's it's just timing um
timing and luck and you know you take
companies like
like like tesla um
and and and and and really you know the
the original tesla
um you know sort of pre
um elon
was kind of doing sort of okay
but but but he just drove them
and because he had a
really strong vision you know he would
he would make calls
that were always you know or
well mostly pretty good i mean the model
x was
kind of a goofball thing to do but he
did it boldly anyway
like there's so many people that just
said
like there's so many people that oppose
them on the falcon one door like the
doors yeah
from the engineering perspective those
doors are ridiculous
it's like yeah they're they are a
complete travesty
but but they're but they're exactly the
symbol
of what great leadership is which is
like you have a vision and you just go
like if you're gonna do something stupid
make it really stupid yeah and go all
in yeah yeah and
and you know to musk
credit he's a really sharp guy
so going back in time a little bit to
steve jobs
you know steve jobs was a similar sort
of character who had
a strong vision and was really really
smart
and you you know and he wasn't smart
about the technology parts of things
but but sort of he he was really sharp
about
the the the sort of
human relationship between you know the
relationship between humans and objects
um and but
he was a jerk you know
right can we just linger on that a
little bit like people say he's a jerk
um is that a feature or a bug well
that's that's that's the question right
so you take people like
steve um it was
really hard on people and and the and so
the question is
was he really was he needlessly hard on
people
or was he just making people reach
to to meet his vision
and you could kind of spin it either way
um well the results tell a story
you know he's uh he through whatever
jerk ways he had
he made people often do the best work of
their life
yeah yeah and that was absolutely true
and you know i interviewed with him
several times
um i did you know various
negotiations with him and
um
even though kind of
personally i liked him i could never
work for him
why do you think uh that what
can you put into words the kind of
tension that you feel would be
um destructive as opposed to
constructive
oh he he he'd yell at people he'd call
him names
um and you don't like that no
no i don't i don't think you need to do
that yeah
um and
you know he you know i think you know
there's there's
pushing people to excel um
and then there's too far and i think he
was on the wrong side of the line
and i've never worked for musk i know a
number of people who have
many of them that have said and it's you
know shows up in the press a lot that
that musk is kind of that way and
one of the things that i sort of loathe
about silicon valley these days
is that um a lot of the high-flying
successes are run by people who are
complete jerks
um but it seems like there's been
become this there's come this this sort
of mythology out of
steve jobs that the reason that he
succeeded
was because he was
super hard on people and
and and and and and and in
a number of corners people start going
oh if i want to succeed
i need to be a real jerk yeah right
and and and that for me just does not
compute
i mean i know a lot of successful people
who are not jerks
who are perfectly fine people
um you know they they tend to
not be in the public eye the
the the general public somehow lifts the
jerks up into the
into the hero status right well they
because they're they do things that get
them in the press
yeah and you know the people who
um you know
don't do the kind of things that spill
into the press
um yeah i just uh talked to chris ladner
um for the second time
he's a super nice guy just an example of
this kind of kind of individual that's
in the background
i feel like he's behind like a million
technologies but he also talked about
the jerkiness of some of the folks yeah
yeah
and the fact that being a jerk has
become your required style
you